yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
this is our Monday evening show and I
welcome all of you in the YouTube chat
hope you had a good Monday who some of
our selfish so some dropping frames i
really don't hope that is a that is an
issue oh I don't know
yeah please let me know if this stream
is working correctly I don't know what
the dropped frames issues they don't
have that usually okay anyway that's um
let's get going going to play a couple
of 5-minute games of course and going to
kick this off and I have to say that um
I'm not going to play any crazy openings
today nor that we you know anything and
the reason is something that you can
spot right away when the first game is
going to start um what is this card give
me a game game start here it is against
mr. blue green you see my rating it's to
337 that's not looking good I dropped
100 points yesterday and really didn't
play well I was somewhat somewhat tired
yesterday and it didn't didn't didn't go
well at all so I want to try to get some
some points back today and the Latvian
or stuff like that it's not the way to
go okay playing blue green yet see I'm
going to place play this beam Oni here
hmm that's an interesting way of playing
I think I'm going to take and play there
should be three yeah whenever I feel
whenever I feel whenever I drop below
2400 I feel like hmmm yeah I feel like
something is gone wrong and I think this
is really true so let's see what happens
here
I think before
is a good idea here now I want to play
the Kings gambit today this is totally
totally sure okay so I would like to get
in c5 here might be five is not doing
the trick
cheeks Bishop Jake's and d6 96 and c5
let's try oh there's a question what
would I recommend two of what blunders
if you are not used to OTB games any
kind of concentration technique um well
I don't know the thing is you have to be
concentrated also in in online chess and
the thing is what's a big difference if
you are really a distracted vibe and
let's say noises or things like that
then you maybe you can think about you
putting something in your ears there's
there are those those plugs that you can
use and maybe this is something that
that is helpful for you but you have to
be sure what Jack what the precise
reason is before you can can fight this
concentration issue it can also be just
a matter of matter of time that you have
to that you have to be concentrated
longer let's say in over the board games
maybe this is a matter of stamina like
you don't have problems with blitz but
yeah it's it's it's a question of being
concentrated for a longer time it's it's
really difficult to say it definitely
helps to play more over the board this
is one thing that's totally sure
okay so how to do that Bishop d5 looks
easy it's probably going king a queen 37
okay six yeah that looks good
the Schleck does laughs Wow this is the
this is a really really stodgy opening
do you feel that's interesting to play I
mean I play mine my fair share of
somewhat boring openings but the
schlecht us love is really boring okay I
try to be ready for potential you for
move
I can't let's go here it's Ruby five
something maybe rougane five
yeah requesting a Schlachter Slav is
rare that was really rare okay Ruby
something I think I'll just get all them
all my pieces in the game root K is six
might have been good already
well okay one can hardly be a mistake um
okay I think I'll go get six now really
don't see why is that not why that
shouldn't work
those pawns were made for walking and
that's just what they'll do what was the
lyrics something like that right I think
I think I'll take this for Queen f7 d 7r
d7 was also pretty strong but let's have
a look rook takes us also pretty strong
threatens trend trends quite a bit 47
Bishop takes us actually strongest I
guess I don't play the gropes attack now
I want to gain points today I really
want to just score getting back from
that miserable to 337 yeah after I think
Bishop g7 now and I think he only has
the one check on c1 and a threatening
look edge file f4 made so okay rook h5
is not made now unfortunately but it's
there check them not really so I can go
here and there should be five I will
take okay
checkmate okay that's the first win for
tonight and I hope not the last let's
see game started hey Eddie Russell man
says my coach taught me refutation of
the nimzo-indian should I just quit his
lessons
no please send me the refutation maybe I
can make some money out of that gee
Bianchi okay interesting that's a
question about the French defense if I
see that as a good option yeah of course
the French is a very interesting opening
it's one of those openings that check
that can serve you very well if you know
it well it's not something that I think
should be played I don't know yeah just
give it a go and hope for the best it's
a specialist opening this is actually
the same opinion that Peter suite last
about it and I kind of borrow his his
lines there he said that he feels that
the French can be an excellent choice if
you devote lots of study time then it's
the French has somewhat unique positions
and unique problems in a way and this is
something that can be very rewarding if
you if you study it correctly for
example morozova Chander the Russian
player he was very successful with the
French defense not just because of his
creative play but also because he put in
lots of work there yeah this is actually
not going well here I'm think I have a
pretty bad two Knights defense IAM
there's a yes remark attack Kasparov
said that all the mainland openings are
fundamentally sound that's probably true
Liam I mean you won't refute I know
the girl felt on the caro-kann or
anything like that that's just not going
to happen the friendships I have an
opening that you have to also you need a
good feel for that yeah it's a it's an
opening where you often have a space
disadvantage for example and you have to
maneuver correctly and it's not for
everyone everyone I can definitely tell
you that I am bad at playing the French
I tried it a lot and I at one point came
to the conclusion to give it up because
I simply don't play it well so you have
to find out for yourself if you are a
French player or not it's not for
everybody this is of course something
that applies to almost all openings why
is only five played at top level now
that's a great question and I think the
reason is that with p45 currently they
have a very very narrow let's say field
of openings that they that they consider
to be critical it's mostly the Rhodope s
and they're there the Bolinas is very
sturdy and tough to break down I think
there are just less less options for
white that they consider critical in the
Sicilian there are some more oh it's
just grabbing this pawn greedy
very very greedy and it's also
fashionable it is definitely also some
some some case that they did they are I
think a particular line is interesting
and then they
kind of yeah play it on and on and on
and on
okay here I'm opening up the position
and let's see what happens I think I
wasn't I wasn't serious trouble maybe I
still am but I am not so sure anymore
okay so what to do here
Bishop hangs and flee this fire for
something yeah the Italian game is
having a slight comeback and I think
this is mostly due to the Berlin being
so popular no no beer today nope not
today okay ambition nice night six
hmm I forgot about this move but anyway
you cannot just take a couple of times
as Bishop c5 is winning stuff yeah isn't
that kind of shaky what he has here too
hard to believe here all this okay I'll
give them four Queen to f6 looks very
dangerous
yeah hello to all of you in the chat
again many regulars some new guys oh
it's cool to see new yeah faces would be
wrong we don't have faces but new names
and here Queens I have six is the normal
move I just wonder if I have something
better and that if three doesn't seem to
work
Queen f6 he goes rook F one which is
then maybe Bishop h5 let's do this yeah
the advanced French is quite popular I
never understood why like us normally
find them and probably because people
like to have this this clear structure
yeah white is now losing some material
him somehow got too much active play at
one point no III you see three winning
here taking this on probably then III
yep I always got to check there that's
that's stupid
hmm look to check Wow whoa whoa whoa
should let it do this then that that's
very bad big blunder here and totally
unnecessary blunder to try to keep the
porn
that's still not so easy I hope check I
look at two and now I'm blundering
everything right shoot I still could
have played whatever it was interesting
still ah yeah that was bad I just wish
there was just a piece up here and
completely winning yeah that doesn't
work though any normal movements Queen
f6 or something okay okay that's a
question if I have considered the wolf
start variation with five B five and the
two nights I don't think this is a
correct line I don't think it is good
game it has a question if I think that
kayaking could be a tougher opponent for
this year for Magnus then then then
Vichy maybe maybe but I still think he's
a heavy favorite question do I look
forward to a tournament yeah I know I
have a tournament planned and know in
the summer actually I'm going to play an
open tournament in Slovenia in in Porto
Rose Otto Roche I could probably cannot
pronounce that correctly this is the
famous place where the I think one of
the candidate tournaments were in his
own tournaments was held in the 1950s or
early 60s
yeah I'm trying a new line he was g6
there is no match yet scheduled with
Simon Williams I probably have to
contact him Korea should do that it will
be will be probably quite funny I think
he recently played a match where where
he played the Kings gambit every game
that sounds funny no I didn't I didn't
the the night of Memorial in Warsaw was
very interesting but I did not go for
that because that open tournament in
Slovenia is fantastic for me because I
will visit this this country anywhere
Porto Roche yes right and I will visit
this anywhere for my regular let's say
non chess holiday so basically yeah
cutting down on my co2 footprint and
just go one way to the tournament and my
holiday right after so it's just a very
convenient way of combining two things
okay what the heck
I understand his point but still the
position is rather closed after that so
that seemed I took with the b-pawn I was
thinking he would take with the Sheep I
with a deep horn and then Bishop c4
interesting
yeah I need to get some revenge and
against Maxine blue gee he really won
from a very very lost position yesterday
but what can you do
the last time I opened one f4 as white
in a classical tournament game against
someone above mm hmm 2013 my opponent
was mm something rated 2070 or so but I
have played one year for tournament
chess also against stronger players some
years ago against I am so also in
grandmasters I mean I was playing before
a long time ago a no long time ago not
in a galaxy far far away but a long long
time ago a try Bishop h6 see I would be
nice ok so he wants
I had Rudi said I have to explain what
went wrong well that's pretty easy to
say I didn't take one of those plus six
lines that were available when they were
a couple
yes lavinius were some very nice places
I've been I've been to some W Allah is
nice of course but blade is also a great
absolutely great place to be yeah he's
got a bishop there on e6 and this is not
nice to play against I mean that Bishop
is never taking anything here but
I wonder I cannot do much in this
position 9f5 you will take yeah
sir grip is not far away from that place
where usually spend my holidays about
6070 miles maybe and the reason for the
English opening English openings
popularity at the moment is that the
players who play closed games usually
and so the d4 93 guys they don't have
anything against the Greenfeld so this
is why they play the English what is
this um hmm I can take their night eh I
don't see why that does not win why is
that not winning
okay
f3 okay I don't see why not
check
why is that not winning yeah I could
have gone to d4 but
so I'm winning the the Queen iam and
what issue is that he doesn't really
have many squares here Lucas really
really bad so chick don't want to screw
this up
King here maybe right
yep
it's Slovenia different than Austria
because of the sea and Slovenia only has
a very small coastline it's just a
couple of couple of kilometers
I mean I don't play one therefore I
definitely won't yeah
what a guy Atkins chances may be 30% or
something it's not something whatever I
didn't think about this for long before
I giving you that a estimate but
something like that one difference
between Slovenia and Austria is that
Slovenia has a little bit less tourism
it's not it's not that not that crowded
let's say and I think there's some part
of the nature nature is less influenced
by tourism but there are there are
clothes there are clothes of course in
terms of the scenery and so on
yeah good food and beer you can also get
in Slovenia it's kind of a coincidence
that I'm going there that often it just
just happened that I found a good place
that way I can stay and this was quite
is really quite nice okay um he tries to
go d5 I guess
a good question without consciousness
what would you play with black if you
needed to win badly
the Kiwanis last round in the candidates
I think that his choice with them with
them with them come on with the Sicilian
was was pretty good I think that was a
good choice and I think he was very okay
in that game so I think he would
probably do exactly the same thing again
in terms of opening choice against
deform it's more difficult a choice
quite obvious choice would be the Dutch
defense something that Caruana has
played in fact and serious tournament
games when he wanted some some more
enterprising play and it's it's quite
possible it's possible that he may have
would have done that but it was pretty
yeah not obvious obvious is wrong but
the likelihood was very high anyway that
kayaking would go money for he's a
natural one efore player from his youth
and it's also just the easier move to
play for him for a draw with on play for
a draw is wrong but it's a safe and
moving away as there are so many forced
drawing lines that black has to avoid
mmm the question if I play the
tournament to qualify for the match with
Council on Chester come yeah there is
this qualification stuff but I don't
think I can actually I mean first of all
it will probably be out of my league to
get this qualification spot but I
probably cannot attend to the tournament
anyway it's I think at times where I'm
teaching what would I play okay
in this must-win situation yeah probably
some Sicilian this is this is probably
what I would do against you for it's
difficult still to play for win if you
absolutely have to it still some
Sicilian and against deform this is
actually a bit of a problem with my
opening rapper - I don't have a clear to
go to opening with black for for playing
for win I play I have a lot of solid
lines in my repertoire but not so much
that can can be used to really play hard
for a win
so maybe the Dutch but it's it's tough
there's a discussion in the chat about
different brands of vice via the
Bavarian type of beer yeah I also like
it and that as I already mentioned in
earlier streams of also I like the
non-alcoholic version a lot which is
kind of unusual but I think it's really
pretty ok all non Belgian beers are
dishwater that's not true I'm also a
huge fan of pilsner urquell so the Czech
beers are also very good style ramen is
also not bad ok what did you hear it's
not so easy
ruk ruk g6 or something don't like that
rooks is six assists a bit lame I don't
I don't want to do that so maybe still
this
against 1.d4 I play I really play my
book repertoire play the new missile and
Bogor Indian a bit but I'm pretty
flexible I didn't think about this move
at all which shows that I'm not in good
shape if you don't see a mate in one
threat you you have problems
Wow
okay I can grab now on d5 yeah I think I
will create three no one Queen f3
hmm sorry tough here to do anything it's
it's a porn but not fun
do I get to trade the signal threatens
to take on edge for I guess okay no not
if I move the rook so maybe I move the
rook here I came I can shake him now
here and Queenie to was also possible
and absolutely don't like this position
just Queen f5 and he's still attacking
him okay time morning
Oh gauge five probably not just take it
okay it's fried blunder stuff and it's
not go there because of Queenie of three
can't do much here I'm glad that I
didn't get checkmated here to be honest
could have happened check check check
check check check check check check
can you wait to play for win check okay
all right tough game
it was nice at the end so then it could
got got problematic
okay so um another question what what
the heck what is the question if I
should blitz kibitzing okay that's a
cool idea yeah maybe I should do that
some more blitz cue it sing
yeah yeah I'll play my a total mainline
stuff here
and see what happens maybe I should do
that
um yeah thanks for the nice feedback on
the 3-minute games I'm glad that glad
you like them I always good fun I wonder
if that is correct
but something something went wrong here
in this position Queen B 626 is bad
right my bad been opening a bad opening
now that's very bad actually
hmm Wow
I totally confused lion C and I know I'm
in trouble
oh he wants to give me that b3 porn
hmm yeah it's tough to not take this
night if five is also I think I'll take
this immediately there's a question what
do I think about chess960 yeah it's it's
kind of it's a mixed bag it's I think
it's interesting for someone interesting
to play but it has it has its issues it
has issues and the main issue is that I
think in chess960 you don't really get
interesting games that often I know
there probably are people who think this
is the best ever because you don't have
this opening theory and I actually like
this idea that you don't have that much
opening theory I mean I am known for
being theoretically yeah quite um I know
I know theory and it's it's just
chess960
is probably robbing me of some some of
my advantages let's say but what I
really don't like in this game is
sometimes you have immensely immensely
inharmonious let's say uh pneumonias
positions you start with something where
everything is wrong yeah you have I
don't know the pieces aren't too totally
wrong squares and this is sometimes just
leading to awful kind of games
it just looks awful and I really have
seen truly interesting chess960 games I
mean there are probably they probably
exist but it's not that I'm not really
aware of them maybe you have to refresh
the stream it's probably some YouTube
hiccup
yeah what is happening in this game he
has given me this opponent maybe he has
compensation some compensation not sure
but will seem
yeah I'm happy to trade stuff of course
yeah those those hiccups with the stream
it's more I think a more YouTube issue
it's not so much about your your
bandwidth at home yeah I really cannot
do much on my end everything's cool or
maybe there is there is really an issue
no that works ping works no I can
restart the stream I mean I can do that
I did I did I did restart the screen
yeah in the meantime my opponent
blundered some stuff
yeah why destroy and hard to get some
color to play with it doesn't seem to be
so dangerous
no c4 is an idea I had just cover
everything in Queen e7 for Queen takes
c3 is also pretty strong so let's do
this there's a question why I don't stop
one of my students to play the
Alekhine's defense as his main opening
well there's nothing particularly wrong
with that opening okay so I don't I
don't usually influence my students that
that badly with with landings if they
are okay with what they play and usually
get decent position there's no way
there's not there's not a reason to
change that game started okay I've
gained a couple of points but now we get
to the serious guys keep mr. Killian
Carlo tomorrow
I had a game yesterday against Hawaii
played a very strange line against my
against the super Bishop g4 he he
continues to play that I think this is
really rubbish amazing okay we'll see I
think this is really really garbage okay
so maybe 93 what is your idea mr. demora
what the beep this looks weird to put it
mildly
yeah 97 is the not-too-subtle threat and
yeah okay I can take with the bishop now
I think I will
let's do it there's six me yeah I can
still just go back and keep that idea it
would be somewhat messy still but I'm
still taking stuff
okay that's a question what do I think
of the plan to only study openings when
one reaches 2008 Oh in the five minute
ICC pool well I think you can start
earlier and it I mean opening study
sometimes gets some some yeah there's
some some people think that you you
shouldn't do it at all I know I could
have taken the route but c4 is hanging
with a check and this is also very
strong I think you should also study
some openings when you are lower rated
but the focus on on this study should
not be learning concrete lines but
understand the principles behind the
stuff that you play and try to Jack yeah
try to try to understand the actual
ideas of what you do and this is I think
something that can be quite useful even
at a lower rating level okay um what
happens here I think I think 995 know I
have bishops in stone so maybe just this
okay of course I only already I already
regret that I didn't didn't take the
exchange but what can you do
there's a question if I ever heard a
1938 interview with Ella Coyne some
things he said kind of shocked me like
you don't need good memory to become
good I think you need a good memory am
and chance I mean it depends on what
what you what good means I mean for
world champion you need excellent memory
for becoming a grandmaster it shouldn't
be a total sieve but I don't think you
need to be fantastic in that regard I
have grandmaster friends who have
problems with the memory definitely
definite problems okay I can still win
stuff now mmm I wonder what's best I
think I'll take this I mean it's
probably no big difference what I do and
I'm really not sure I mean L account
obviously was a fantastic play of it
it's a long time ago it's really a long
time ago and that I think we nowadays
understand she has much better then
people did in like 80 years ago or 90
years ago okay we're just going back
here play this position with a couple of
extra points
two points
threatening to win the Queen now rook
hope to be one okay he wants to attack
h2 here that's the main idea okay maybe
this now it seems the stream is a bit
unsteady and I don't really know why my
internet connection is fine it looks
fine so I don't know what that is really
look to b6 you maybe attack f6
yeah the stream it's not stable but I
really don't know what it is my internet
connection is really fine I tried to go
wrong to be seven now it's my threat
no I don't think that any any of my
possible over the board opponents would
study the YouTube channel and have an
advantage this way I don't think that
happens okay mm-hmm how to how to finish
this Lukas is 6 on what probably a
couple of moves like to do the trick
probably that's not the most forceful
one check
right there okay jack chickie a 95 or 96
a deep one really should win this I
probably could have done something
better but but I think it's it's enough
yeah I don't I mean I look a little bit
of an option here on the stream and what
is what I do over the board it's it's
not it's not jack not the same stuff
Jack okay
can i play for mate here or something
would like to checkmate in here it's not
made yet no I have six I don't see a
main
hmm no maid that's a shame okay time
warning no that's actually actually
wrong so let's go down check it
definitely wants to get at least some
chicken I guess check check
black forfeit see how those two phones
are all it's pretty good so maybe I can
get to 2400 in the stream that would be
excellent not doing too badly today okay
um now I don't nobody watches this
channel my channel to prepare against me
that'sthat's kind of crazy I don't think
that happens I think actually the
preparation the preparation level gets
sometimes to be overestimated started
okay Rainmaker did I ever consider too
plain a Romania or have a player no I've
never been to Romania no particular
reason why not sound like I'm avoiding
it or anything it's just that I have
never considered a tournament there is
there anything interesting
now and I have no idea how to pronounce
the capital of Romania correctly because
it's Bucharest in German but trying to
pronounce that with some kind of English
flavor is probably leading to two big
big entertainment for many people it me
me try to do that okay um interesting he
tries to put pressure on f5 him that
night is hanging but
hmm how much time doing this in my own
prep when playing serious tournament mmm
it depends a lot on the on the on that
tournament sometimes you just don't have
much time anyway
and I don't invest that much time
anymore on preparation if I excel
exhaust myself there I often assume they
don't have the power to to play decent
in the actual game zone and quite often
not doing that much also I played many
of my tournaments oh yeah when I'm when
I'm on holiday that same and sometimes
you just don't have any time okay
interesting
so now I'm going 95
I don't think sacrificing the queen is
any good so I'm ready to jump in to see
three or a three depends a bit on what
he does this one who came to Seoul
I could just jump in that's not totally
off on this
after this he might take place I if I
don't know about that
what about night before by the way I
have five is hanging on so Wow okay the
difference between preparation for
tournament and studying well if you play
a tournament many things are very much
focused on short-term things I get a
particular opening fixed or things like
that
and general studying is about really
playing better in general so this is
maybe a difference
yeah tough position here against the
Rainmaker I think yeah I don't know what
I think actually I wanted to say I think
he's probably better but I'm not sure
about it yeah here I can take a five I'm
quite quite sure what his point is if I
can take this pawn I will take it it's
just too important not to take in 94 is
coming so what did i do tonight
I lost one game he had that two nights
defense where blunder the piece but
other than that I did okay okay here
anything can still happen but I'm very
happy with this position
so what's the deal he wants to do to
hear it but 94 93 is just it's just very
good
taking on c5 it's not possible I take G
- oh he wants to get the rook into the
game understandable
25 it's 225 yeah I have h5 year this is
just the thing
oh wait good SIA okay I was briefly
thinking queen edge fire but they'd
wouldn't work
I don't see I don't see a tactical
strike for him okay well it's a cool
move he wants to play rogue age five Wow
Wow
okay I think I can do this though
yeah that looks good okay if you get
skype messages during a live stream it
gets tricky
okay Queen f4 I cannot play
yeah I don't see anything okay try to
take six I go King Jade and I'm fine or
you see I don't really believe it I also
might have King g8 coming up maybe I can
get a winnin and get back to 2400 time
that'd be really neat okay yeah this is
also I think I'll do that come on it
feels right check open and open this up
25 door let's just step out of this
not so good yet time boys you have to be
quick
we're winders yeah it's it's a it's an
excellent position it really is but I
don't see a direct win here maybe I have
to take care just to open the table even
though giving up the bishop panics wrong
and okay this I can do it now check
check check check check
it's okay oh I got that one in at two or
three ninety five to three ninety five s
still like like five minutes
okay I will go for one more game
definitely I wanted I want to try to get
to to a normal rating again to three
ninety five so game started is it weird
to attend a country where where you
don't speak the language well well
English gets you very far nowadays I was
completely happy to play in Poland no no
problem whatsoever for example and I
don't speak one word I mean okay maybe
like no way I forgotten the two or three
words that I actually managed I'm really
bad that way not good at picking up
foreign languages that I don't know at
all okay so let's see what we can do
against jianci here have a Queens gambit
declined very classical stuff
try to play tempo game here and see what
is doing here you can go c5 it's not
okay this is also quite usual b5 I can
go c5 I interesting that's an
interesting way to play it
hmm maybe this one is that interesting I
can go to a form makes it a bit more
enterprising
yeah it was interesting here there are a
couple of ideas
after f6 for example I can play Bishop
d3 I think and sacrifice there's a
question what the best game is an
airplane I have no idea
I don't play many really spectacular
games I think there are probably lots of
players with a similar playing strengths
we have from played more more
interesting and more spectacular games
than I have herds very very likely
actually ok so Bishop d3 probably wasn't
the greatest idea here
Wow very tough
okay so d5 there's 95 which is not
exactly great that if force toughest is
annoying yeah of course that's not the
position that I wanted I just had a very
nice position out of the opening and now
it's complete chaos this guy is more of
a tactical player anyway hmm not good
Bishop d3 was a bad move
I guess this doesn't look good at all
yeah a knight takes I would have to do
this I guess she was hanging
he's taking his time this is one of the
positive things him Wow check yeah
before his sir is coming which that I
understand would still kind of surprised
here and said what what black is going
for him
hmm how'd you get them always got before
coming well where should my queen go
probably them now the positioning is
very very bad I think I'm objectively
speaking I'm just losing here but you
never know yeah I don't get to g6 I need
I need to sacrifice their badly and he's
God before I could have done that
earlier but somehow he did he didn't
okay before yeah he's got this [ __ ] one
before this is the worst part
maybe he goes c5 or something I don't
think this is so dangerous I have to
play time bonus
what is time bonus play on time yeah
it's a bit early maybe at 5:00 is
actually getting interesting but
objectively speaking this cannot be good
okay is going on the long diagonal Queen
to d5 maybe anyway there's no way back
here anymore you have to have to just
push him yeah
but taking it's not working but it's
close right e2 is very lame
maybe d3s winning now Wow
time warning
Wow
check and now I'm going to check all the
windows on time check which was the sole
idea of the whole thing him yes okay so
I kind of I kind of tricked myself into
this into this win and I got to four to
408 so good job good job
yeah this wasn't the most clean whenever
but I'll take it to get back to a good
good rating okay guys I hope you enjoyed
it it was it was tough and it was a bit
serious today but I wanted to definitely
get my rating back to something normal
okay I hope you enjoyed it I'll be back
next Monday of course bye bye